You know, we often think of
cowardice as, well, trembling or
anyway, basically a lack of
guts, right?
It could.
It's always painted as this
negative thing, a weakness you
need to fix.
But what if that's completely
wrong?
What if, what if cowardice isn't
a flaw at all, but actually a
really deep kind of wisdom, a
strategy?
That's the pretty startling idea
we're going to get into today.
That comes from our source
material, the virtue of
cowardice, Courage without
bravery in a world obsessed with
performance.
So our mission here is to really
unpack that conventional
thinking and see how this
redefined cowardice could
actually be, Oh well, a
powerful, even predictive type
of courage.
It's less about running away and
more about, say, really
calibrated actions, perfect
timing, and thinking about the
long game.
Let's dive in.
It really does just flip the
script immediately, doesn't it?
The source acknowledges how we
normally see it.
You know, timidity, dodging
responsibility.
But then it hits you with this
paradox.
It asks, what if cowardice,
rightly understood, is not
weakness but wisdom?
Not timidity but timing?
And then what if cowardice is
courage?
With a Longview, that question
alone, it just forces you to
reconsider everything.
It frames cowardice as strategic
intelligence right from the
start.
Yeah, that line really grabbed
me too, because it feels so
backwards, doesn't it?
And like you said, the source
makes it clear this isn't about,
you know, getting out of doing
things.
It actually calls it a strategic
treatise to disguise as a
personality defect.
It paints this picture of
someone like operating
effectively but quietly, almost
like the person who walks
softly, not because you're weak,
but because you know exactly how
heavy your stick is.
That really challenges the whole
idea that strength has to be
loud, you know, visible.
Exactly.
That it's about real presence,
real impact, not just showing
off.
And the source stresses, this
isn't about not hacking, it's
about the calibration of it.
It suggests being so observant,
having such foresight, that your
first motion is already your
final one.
Which leads to this idea of
courage that isn't just reacting
in the moment, but it's deeply
predictive.
You're already setting things up
before the confrontation even
starts.
It pulls in some heavy hitters
to back this up, like Sun Tzu,
right?
Victorious warriors win first
and then go to war.
Well, defeated warriors go to
war first and then seek to win.
Yes, that's a key one.
And Machiavelli too advising to
conceal your intentions until
the moment of execution.
So as you're hearing this, I
mean, does this challenge your
own gut feelings about what
strength or success looks like?
Oh, absolutely, it has to.
I think if you follow this line
of thought, it makes a really
sharp distinction between, let's
call it predictive courage and
reactive bravery.
Reactive bravery, That's the
banner response, right?
Reacting to a threat may be
under pressure, often without
thinking about the cost.
But this cowardice, this
predictive courage, it's about
strategic patience, waiting.
And that can be incredibly
powerful because you've sort of
already rigged the game before
it even starts.
Victory becomes almost, well,
inevitable.
OK, but if bravery is so
admired, how does the source
argue it can actually be a
disadvantage?
That seems like a huge claim.
Says something pretty blunt like
bravery gets people killed,
Bravery charges machine guns.
Yeah, it's harsh, but it makes.
A point and it suggests this
type of bravery is often just
for show.
Like I must be seen risking
something to prove something.
Is that the idea?
That's exactly the idea.
It argues that that kind of
bravery is often impulsive,
maybe even self sacrificial, and
it really needs an audience,
needs that external validation.
It's spectacle, the quiet
courage of this cowardice,
though it it.
It doesn't need a ribbon or a
citation.
What it needs is a map, a fall
back position, and enough
rations to outlast your enemies.
The difference is huge.
The brave die for the crowd.
The coward, if he's wise, lives
for the mission.
It's about making it through,
not just one heroic moment.
Wow, lives for the mission.
Yeah, that's that's a really
different way to frame it.
So this whole approach, it kind
of pushes back against what the
source calls the aesthetic of
confrontation.
You know, that pressure we feel
to always push back, have that
moral clarity wrapped in
slogans, right.
But the source is saying, look,
great conflicts are never won in
slogans.
They're one with intelligence,
understanding the details, the
supply chains, and basically the
refusal to reveal what cards
you're holding.
I love this line.
What others call silence, I call
surveillance.
It's a powerful reframe.
And it makes you think, doesn't
it?
How often does jumping into that
visible brave fight actually get
in the way of achieving the real
goal?
I mean, think about Sun Tzu
again.
The supreme art of war is to
subdue the enemy without
fighting.
That's the ultimate strategic
win.
Or when he says feign disorder
and crush him.
It's about misdirection, not
just brute force.
And Musashi too.
Yes, Miami Musashi retreat is
not surrender, it is the
preparation of ground on your
terms.
So this perspective, it forces
you to ask what's the actual
purpose of this action?
Is head on confrontation really
the smartest path, or just the
one that you know feels most
immediately satisfying?
OK, so if this cowardice isn't
about putting on a show, it's
purely about being effective.
The source calls it the legacy
of fieldcraft, not theater,
which makes sense.
It's not flashy, not at all.
It borrows more from Musashi
than Marvel, more from OSS
manuals like those old detailed
spy guys right in from Ted
talks.
Exactly.
It's practical, maybe even a bit
unglamorous.
This kind of cowardice uses
things like decoys.
It weaponizes slowness.
It actually honors the art of
being underestimated.
Underestimated as a weapon.
Yes, that's crucial point.
Cowardice is camouflage, and
camouflage in a world of
Peacocks is the ultimate weapon.
Because if your opponents think
you're harmless or unwilling to
act well, they don't prepare for
what you can really do.
They don't see your next move
coming or the one after that.
It makes me think of that saying
the one from law enforcement the
source uses the most dangerous
man in the room is the one no
one noticed.
Precisely.
And it links back to Sun Tzu's.
To know your enemy, you must
become your enemy, which your
means like quiet deep study, not
open fighting.
So maybe think about your own
life for a second.
Where could being underestimated
or operating more quietly
actually be an advantage for
you?
It's a good question to ask, and
when you look at the bigger
picture, these aren't just
battlefield tactics, they're
strategies for influence, for
long term advantage in almost
any field.
The source points to figures
like Sun Tzu, Machiavelli,
Musashi, even General Jop
strategist famous for their
indirect methods.
They were the ones who whispered
wait and then struck once with
surgical efficiency.
They understood that real power
is often hidden.
OK, but this is really
important.
The source draws a very clear
line here, says the difference
between cowardice and
cowardliness is intent.
Yes, crucial distinction. 1 is a
way of seeing, the other is a
way of shrinking.
So this isn't about actually
being weak or fearful in the
traditional sense.
It's a conscious choice, a
powerful stance.
Absolutely.
It's deliberate and the strategy
it uses time itself as a weapon.
Cowardice is time.
Cowardice is breath.
It's about waiting until the
others have gone mad with their
need to be heard and then
speaking one phrase that clears
the room.
It's about actions that have
huge impact but aren't
necessarily loud or public like
the examples given.
Cowardice is not going to the
protest, but quietly hacking the
infrastructure behind the
scenes.
Right.
Or the other one.
Cowardice is not raising your
voice.
Cowardice is having 10,000
receipts filed, time stamped and
ready for the tribunal that's
coming in five years.
It's about building.
Building leverage quietly.
That is the ultimate long game,
isn't it?
Planning for a tribunal five
years down the line.
So this intelligent coward, as
the source puts it, becomes
unpredictable.
They don't rise to the bait.
They don't throw the obvious
punch.
They don't broadcast their plan.
Wait, they study?
And when he moves, the game has
already shifted.
They come back not with words,
but with leverage.
Exactly.
It really makes you think about
how often those loud, immediate
reactions actually sabotage long
term goals.
It really does this approach,
the strategic cowardice.
It's about building real,
lasting power by, well, changing
the rules of engagement
entirely.
It reflects the wisdom and old
sayings, like that Zulu proverb,
a lion doesn't roar when it
stalks.
Or the Persian one.
The blade you never see is the
one that cuts steepest.
And the Zen saying.
The turtle survives not by
speed, but by shelter.
It's about endurance,
resilience, often by avoiding
the direct fight altogether,
being the one left when the dust
settles.
So to wrap up this deep dive,
we've explored the virtue of
cowardice, looking at it not as
weakness, but as a form of
strategic, maybe even wise
courage.
It's about putting the mission
first, not the performance.
Using restraint, maybe a decoy
sidestep, and definitely
harnessing the power of being
underestimated.
Yeah, it's a complete paradigm.
Shift.
And it leaves us with, I think,
a really provocative question
that you want.
What does it mean for you, in
your own context, to walk softly
but carry a stick so big you
never have to prove it exists?
And maybe if they never even see
you swing that stick, that's
even better.
Because as the source puts it so
well, history isn't usually
written by the stars of the
opening act.
It's written by the ones who are
still standing when the final
curtain falls.
Something to think about.
The power of endurance and
waiting for the right moment.